I have sort of what is delightful news for
you today, even though in practice I don't,
I don't believe it's really going to be a
big deal.
A federal judge has ruled that Donald Trump's
lawyer McGahn must testify to house impeachment
investigators.
Now, I'll tell you the three reasons that
this is tremendous.
And then I'll tell you the one reason why
it may not even matter in the end.
So first of all, number one, what Don McGahn
knows and what he could say, um, would be
explosive and it could single handedly changed
the trajectory of Donald Trump's presidency.
That's reason number one, why this is a big
deal.
Number two, the Trump administration ordered
Don McGahn not to cooperate, to ignore subpoenas,
to ignore requests and forcing him to show
up would really anger Trump and it would throw
him completely into a whole new rage that
would be a really interesting to to to watch.
And judge Katon G Brown Jackson said in her
decision, quote, no one is above the law and
that is what it would mean for Don McGahn
to simply ignore a legal, constitutionally
enshrined subpoenas from the house.
A a house of representatives, a lawyer for
McGahn said his client will obey the court's
ruling to testify, but there are a lot of
ifs, ands and buts in there.
By the way, again, Don McGann's lawyer manga,
it's not make America great again.
As I've said before, it's making attorneys
get attorneys.
Trump lawyer, Michael Cohen really needed
a lawyer, a Trump lawyer, Rudy Giuliani, as
I told you, recently hired three lawyers,
Trump lawyer, Don McGahn.
Now speaking publicly through his lawyer,
Trump makes a lot of attorneys get attorneys.
The third reason that this decision is huge
is that it could impact or signal what will
happen with other witnesses like Donald Trump's
former national security advisor, John Bolton,
who so far has refused to testify until a
federal court weighs in.
Mick Mulvaney is another example, although
Mick Mulvaney his attorney, uh, attorney saying
that, um, his ultimate decision to testify
or not to will not hinge upon what's happening
here with Don McGahn.
We'll see about that.
So now let's back it up.
Number one, there is no doubt that Don McGahn
knows a lot of very incriminating things about
Donald Trump.
The question is, number one, how much of it
relates to Ukraine versus other things since
the impeachment hearings are narrowly focused
on the Ukraine fiasco.
And number two, uh, Don McGahn can show up
and tell us nothing.
Okay.
Don McGahn can show up and invoke his fifth
amendment right.
Uh, more likely can invoke executive privilege,
which is, I mean, I would even say he could
invoke attorney client privilege, but executive
privilege has a higher level of privilege
that can be invoked.
So for now we don't know if and when Don McGahn
might be scheduled to testify.
Of course the Supreme court could issue a
stay and that stay could last a long time,
certainly, uh, through the election.
And even if he does show up, I would, I would
bet that he would assert executive privilege.
So if you ask me today, we have this decision,
will Don McGahn ever testify?
I actually don't know.
Uh, there, there are a number of scenarios
under which this will never see the light
of day.
And sadly, once again, this is becoming an
issue of checks and balances, separation of
powers, and whether a determined administration,
an administration determined to ignore legal,
constitutionally enshrined subpoena powers
and investigatory powers, will it ultimately
go ignored either via stalling or just not
paying attention?
And quite frankly, this attitude of, so what
if we don't has worked pretty damn well for
them so far?
Because that's how it's gone with everything.
Trump talking to Mueller, no, I'll answer
quiz questions in writing and be deceptive
and still molar is not going to go forward
with anything that is going to have a consequence
for Donald Trump, Rudy Giuliani, uh, to provide
documents to Congress.
And now I'm just not going to do it.
Donald Trump's tax returns.
No, just not going to do it.
And even if a court says it, we're not gonna
do it.
And we'll see if ultimately Trump gets away
with that.
That's working its way through the system
right now.
So the right decision by the judge, we will
see if anything comes of it.
We will see if McGann shows up, if he simply
pleads executive privilege invokes executive
privilege.
Anyway, I think the answer is probably yes.
I want to hear from you.
Let me know on Twitter at D Pacman, what do
you think?
Will we ever hear from Don McGahn?
And remember, we've got just a few days until
we do our black Friday membership special.
Don't go buy cheap plastic goods that will
end up in the trash.
Okay.
That's not what black Friday should be about.
It should be about voting your values with
your dollars supporting independent media
among other things and family of course.
Um, get on our newsletter@davidpakman.com
and then on Friday you'll get an email with
a onetime use coupon code
you can use to get a just, it's an ungodly
obscene discount off